hello I'm Doug Brochu and I am a host
for some of the awesomeness TV shows one
being shuvit which is a game show that
involves food and rivalries and just
crazy challenges and lots and lots of
food and messiness and another one is
how to be awesome which is simply a show
where we show kids how to be awesome you
want to do a kickflip great watch this
I'm Alex go ahead also known as jewel
thief and I create a lot of pranks and
comedy skits on YouTube on the channel
written directed produced and acted in
the the serial killers video The Dark
Knight Rises parody for the iPhone 5
prank I dressed up like an Apple
employee and pretended to ship the
iPhone boxes to the stores we have all
these people lined up in the morning of
the release day and I tripped and broke
all of these iPhones in front of the
people who had waited hours and hours
for these products one of the challenges
that we ran into was the fact that there
were security guards lining up the sides
of lines making sure people weren't
cutting and there weren't any riots or
whatever so when we busted out our
cameras to do prank we got shut down
almost immediately at a lot of the
different locations it was one of the
more difficult pranks to pull off and
definitely had quite a few pissed off
customers I was threatened a few times
react we actually had some weird
reactions from the employees who worked
at the Apple Store if you see in the
first clip one of the employees actually
started helping us pick up the boxes as
if he didn't know that it was like oh no
like a real Apple employee was like oh
we gotta fix this and he like picked up
one of the boxes and like trying to you
know
amended the situation and I thought that
was for the hilarious we we also got
some people that just you know we're
speechless one guy's jaw literally
dropped like a cartoon character
this format asked the awesomenesstv
format allows much more freedom
anybody can who has a image of vision in
their mind is so much closer to seeing
that vision made real then with a
network show where you have to go
through all these things you have to
pitch it to these people who might not
necessarily like have the same vision
and go do that so in this you say okay
friends got a camera let's spend a day
making a set and let's do this thing and
then from there you can build up I guess
your reputation so it's it's it's very
liberating shooting it and then seeing
it it looks like there's a lot more food
than there actually is I guess that's
just the nature of the transition from
real life to film but man it was when I
when we were filming and I'm thinking
yeah this is pretty disgusting I'm
pretty I'm pretty disgusted by this but
when we watched it on the the screen of
the computer and we were doing like you
know like dubbing fruits lines that I
had missed it would you know like the
close-ups people like it was like a
little sick to my stomach
uh well you can look for more how to be
awesome from me as well as I'm doing a
little writing right now so we might see
that come see the lie today that's what
I got on my plate I'm writing and
directing a webseries for awesomeness in
February so you can probably hope to see
that in March that's what I'm most
looking forward to producing actually of
all the stuff I've made for Awesomeness
I'm very excited to get started on this
project um I can't really release too
many details but it's essentially Ferris
Bueller for the online world we've done
a lot of fun things and
I'm excited to start on the next one
check out the awesomeness TV channel
youtube.com slash awesomeness TV check
me out on how to be awesome as well as
shove it check me out on awesomeness TV
as well I am jewel thief and all my
stuff is on the randomness playlist